samedi il ya deux semaines
jaâfar émission
phare c'est là où
je le redis habite mon père parce que je
suis obligé me nadji là où habitait mon
père
et sa mère visite vous à petit
pas
[Musique]
il était chauffée à la retraite et sa
passion je vais vous dire qu'elle était
de moins de 6 ans de francs cfa tous les
toits
et ma mère
faisait ce qu'elle trouvait avec son
petit comex
petit
par la taille mais grand par ce que ce
commerçant est
parce que ce commerce a souvent payé ma
scolarité
ce commerce
m'a souvent habillés
surtout à noël et pâques
parce qu'à la fin ne tombait pas c'est
la pensée du pape à a il fallait que
maman ça me pue
langil et
que l'un de mes derniers échanges
avec papa
ça va il s'agissait de coire
c'était aussi de parler
des malentendus qu'il avait eu avec moi
et
qui devrait arriver avec eux
de vie de famille de vie de couple
pour moi parce que depuis que nous
sommes tout petits
en plus de la pauvreté
papa et maman se sont souvent disputés
discuté avec beaucoup de violence
verbale
et mes frères et moi nous avons grandi
comme dans une famille qui était
traumatisée par les disputes les
disputes conjugales
et zara ratier
les psychologues histoire que les
enfants en talents à reproduire
ce qu'ils ont vécu dans leur enfance
c'est ça non
mais moi depuis tout petit
j'avais un rêve
qu'ils avaient avancé que c'est de la
psychologie mais on fout de moi je
voulais faire mentir les psychologues
les faits menti
en montrant peu qu'elle reçoit
ce qu'on avait vu dans leur enfance
on peut travailler à cheveux nous ne
saurions point est victime quel que soit
le traumatisme que nous avons connue
mais le transformions tout un
enseignement
puis
à bas
niveau mais maman n'était était loin
d'être mauvaise mais
il avait du mal à s'entendre siècle
mais ils ont toujours tenu à nous
enseigner ce qui sait que la famille
et
un jour
je leur apprends pas les chauffeurs et
je voulais venu pousser chez ses parents
on va dire à l'école
et ce jour là c'était un joug de
résultats
j'ai ou pas de cet épisode c'est parce
que c'est l'un des plus grands souvenirs
que je garde le papa
l'arrivée
et l'écart à deux places ont couru vers
lui elio di maxima était deuxième de la
classe
et vous allez c'est que tu n'as pas
rallier
jerry
il me dit viens mais dans la voiture
il m'a appris à la main voici que les
enfants des parents
ils osent elles avaient beaucoup de mal
et quelle sera la réaction du patron
et pétrir la pâte rock pas aussi penser
lorsqu'on est arrivé vous quittez projet
enfin à peine
la maman et les enfants nous avons à la
porte
papa dit ces mots fils était deuxième de
la classe
il fallait bien justifier
la raison pour laquelle tina la moitié
hui
il l'a fait après ça nous avons fait
quelques courses avec la patronne il est
le gris d'épouser la voiture
ils m'appuient 600 vélos nous allons lui
laisser la vie juste à la maison
oui
aujourd'hui je prends cela avec le
sourire alors à ce moment c'est vraiment
puissant
plus trempe mais je ne devais pas
laisser cette frustration mais trouver
de mes objectifs
parce que j'avais deux objectifs
dans la vie
le premier
[Musique]
c'était d'avoir un couple exemplaire
le deuxième
c'était de sortir
mes parents du tout visé financiers
comment faire policier s'était réduit
ces défis et vous savez dans la vie
très souvent on nous présente ces deux
des filles
comme
une balance
et ses parents se voir
c'est vie professionnelle et goûter
vie familiale de l'autre
et laurent nous présente souvent cette
part ans
on nous demande de choisir
pour les femmes on les a convaincus que
leur horloge biologique ne le permet pas
de réussir les vues
quant à nous les hommes on nous a fait
croire qu'il ait lieu pour nous de
mettre l'accent sur la vie
professionnelle et le laisser la vie
familiale auf arguments sans m'occuper
de moi je voulais tout avoir dans la vie
et la vie lorsqu'un nombre d qui veut
tout avoir il faut le voir par chacun de
nous nous avons mis quelque chose de
différent dans notre
dame en tout j'avais simplement mis de
18 d'ici 6
10 8 6
que voulez-vous avoir votre vie
aujourd'hui
quelques mois on vous impose de faire un
choix entre deux choses qui comptent
vraiment pour
celles comme moi refuser de choisir
le refuser de choisir
des titres que vous voulez tous
ses saints est très limitée
et dont nous nous devions nous devrons
tout avoir dans la vie il n'avait pas le
tout avant vous possédez dans l'excès il
ne savait pas le tout d'avoir parlé
mais tout à voir
pour un modèle pour être une source
d'inspiration
pour tous ceux là qui
ne l'est plus pour ce qui concerne leur
vie professionnelle
est la monnaie de famille pour tous ceux
là qui ne croient plus ni hors mariage
ni à la famille
nouvoitou d'avoir les avis
et c'est ce combat
que l'on régénération bateliers
d'année le combat et de
l'entrepreneuriat mais avant tout le
combat de la famille
il est dit
que les grandes nations
sont formés par des familles forte
mais la famille faute
mais ce composé que de couple solide
alors à ceux qui sont plus jeunes
allons nous nous laisser limité
allons nous nous laisser bien des
barrières parce que simplement il n'ya
plus d'assez de famille modèle je crois
que non
nous devons continuer de croire au
mariage
nous quoi
il est encore possible
de ne pas aller à l'angle de la
difficulté mais en revenant vers la
forêt de zhouqu chine
parce que c'est aussi
et au delà la possibilité nous devons en
faire un devoir
nous devons en faire un devoir
et relever ce défi
oui de quoi l'accord
de la famille et le mariage sont abbas
et le récit sans professionnellement
nous devons aussi nous donner à fond
lorsqu'il s'agit de nous battre pour
notre foyer de l'oubangui pour nous
notre couple
ayant envie de se battre la famille les
enfants voient souvent ce parc pour les
enfants
majeurs lundi avant le départ
ben tu vois ton époux bac 3 vous votre
amour
hui les hommes en lice aura de mettre
les enfants à l'abri du besoin ces
salons
ne vous savez quel est le premier besoin
quelques nouveaux outils
avant de montrer aux enfants que nous
les six mots montrant leur antre parents
nos musées
parcelier a atterri
que ses parrains j'aime ses devoirs de
ces parcelles
celui de ses parents élèves c'est de
voir que c'est par un cerf
hui mon glorifie ce que mon fils tout
jamais de l'amour que j'ai pour ça mais
bon je vérifie
c'est mes enfants tigre indien
qu'il se souvient de leur père
promettant et a été effectivement en
bout de leur nez
oui ils ont bien que je l'alertais bien
millionnaire je le serai
cela m'apporte
hui
mais je ne néglige pas l'essentiel
les amis
nous avons ici défi
et il ya quelques jours les nez pendant
qu'elle est enfin levé la décennie avec
sa maman ou un couple s'est disputé elle
a demandé à sa maman
qu'elle qui font d'armand dit qu'ils
sont en train de faire la bagarre
mallié femme et vous savez c'est plus ce
qu'elle demande à sa mère que me
trouverez pas beaucoup ne souhaitent pas
la bagarre
ça va chez le psy sentir honoré
les sujets
[Applaudissements]